i am british i
i asked people to say that because
sometimes the accent is confusing to
americans you'd be like oh my god he's
australian
i love australians we're very different
australia in england very different
countries um i think the main difference
is that in australia they have a saying
if you see a very sexy woman
they say
i would crawl across a mile of broken
glass to suck the dick of the last guy
who [ __ ] her
that is what they all say
[Music]
and in england
we don't say that
we say god save the queen that's what we
say
god save the queen that's our motto my
gosh of the lights wow
that joke was so hard they're having an
epileptic fit this is good
i'm not entirely sure we're allowed to
do this there wasn't a sign on the door
that said the show may contain seizures
and a british man
is that like an emergency warning on
your phone or something where they're
like
rip tide alert
okay cool my set is now brought to you
by the makers of mdma let's get
let's get ravy
yeah i feel like there are communities
that would benefit from a light show
behind them i don't think my
mild-mannered british humor is
oh my gosh
i'm sorry
you appeared from nowhere
[ __ ] hell
[Music]
this is uh
this is amazing
do you want to talk us through what's
going on here
other than the health and safety
violation of you trying to trip me up
from behind like this is a playground
well so you've got one of them off
no no are you brave you're british no no
you were just you were just cheering at
the concept of tea
it's awful
okay we're talking about t
what is now these ones are flashing as
well
what is going on
has as lightning struck the clock tower
is the delorean about to appear what's
going on here you know it'd be great if
like if after this show someone goes
chris the lights were fine the whole way
through
the audience didn't know what you were
talking about
you have a bleed on the brain
i mean really at this point i feel like
we should just do that cool thing where
they turn all the lights off everyone
whips their phones out but your phones
are all locked away
i've always dreamt of doing that thing
you know like a concert where they turn
the lights down everyone's like get your
[ __ ] phones i don't want to hold the
torches and the person is like yeah and
everyone else is like this is inadequate
lighting
it doesn't work
i love that you came on the stage turned
this one off well like this [ __ ] does
nothing
okay
cool i'm gonna try and time my punch
lines with the lights flashing
or i'll do that cool thing when they
strobe and people move on stage and it
looks like they're moving really quick
okay we've drained the light based humor
right now
some of you might think we drained it
about three minutes ago when it started
but i am not an improvisational comic
well yes you announced yourself on stage
that time
i think it makes someone's job easier
when you provide running commentary on
it doesn't it
just like
well that one's nailed it did be honest
ladies over here did you press something
you have such cute eyes i'm gonna walk
away before i get an erection in your
face that is
see that's the type of comedy you want
and then the british man comes up and is
like let's talk about the queen we say
god save the queen that's what i was on
do i make it easier if i stand here
[Music]
i've done comedy a long time i'm trying
to go through my mental roller decks of
you're now just making it more groovy
[Music]
if i could do a good travis scott
impression you know i'd be going it's
lit
i don't know it's a good way to end the
evening
okay i do have chucks
i saw a man in a wheelchair with one leg
that was a thing
um he was he was moving the wheelchair
not with the wheels he was moving it by
dragging himself down the street with
his one leg and obviously that is sad
but i can't help what i thought which is
oh that must be how he wore the other
leg down
[Music]
lighten up a bit chris okay yes
it was all for the purpose of a light
pump
well okay right because the the longer
this goes on the more likely that
someone will actually froth at the mouth
and drop on the floor let's um let's
start doing what i do to to close which
is a a magical little thing called
freestyle rap that is rap that is made
up on spot based entirely on suggestions
it's not wow you all just accepted that
like yeah [ __ ] yeah that's how any
show should end chris no matter who is
on stage this time it happens to be you
so freestyle is right made up on the
spot based on whatever you want to rap
about so everyone here think of a word a
topic or a phrase that you'd like to
hear a wrap about there are some rules
number one don't suggest food or animals
it's too obvious and too boring number
two don't be too unimaginative be
creative be you know esoteric if you
wish some of the best suggestions ever
include 9th century crop rotation
and i had a german man who said a day in
the life of an aztec high priest
to aim for that lofty peak okay we'll
get five suggestions i'm assuming that
one of them will be when the lights [ __ ]
up at a comedy show so don't worry
that's that's going in there
did someone put a hand up when i was
looking over here is that you putting a
hand up very politely or you're just
showing off that you've got bangles or
something what would you like a rap
about my friend
rumplestiltskin okay cool for those who
don't know the fairytale character the
abducts babies it's quite
quite a dark story guess my name oh this
will be fun or i'll steal your kid okay
rumplestiltskin great rumplestiltskin
let's come the the kind of there's a big
group over here everyone under here
hello what would you like a rap about
they have inequality income inequality
yes
yes i
when you were like i [ __ ] hate tea i
wasn't expecting you to then be like an
income inequality
rumplestiltskin income inequality
great let's come to you guys over here
oh are you you're waving a candle around
like this is a coldplay concert
um
fantastic stuff what would you like a
rap about over there
was that
the instrument the violin what's the
other definition of the word violin that
you had to add
yeah
maybe yeah okay cool violin great um
middle of the room we haven't come to
you we'll do our wrapper
okay well there were several did you say
andre agassi's mullet yes
that's yeah no he did he used to have
hair
okay
wow your voice sounds too young to know
when that was a thing but
was he who was was he with steffi graf
who was his his like missus
brook shields was it i thought he was
with a tennis player [ __ ]
both at the same time what a player
yeah
okay he was with brook when was he with
brook shields that's the that's the
important thing to find out because
there's a time when it would have been
inappropriate let's so andrea sees
mueller income inequality violins and um
rumplestiltskin final suggestion let's
get it from the back of the room what do
i wrap up
no sorry sorry let's address the fact
that someone just kept going
the suggestion is someone being fingered
at the back of a comedy club that's
that's what the suggestion is
you were like yeah the lights are dim
enough that i can get away with it now
[Music]
okay cool well
what i'm going to say is i'm just trying
to fix the lights obviously please don't
stop the lights being cool when we
actually drop a beat and have fun
because this is really the most
appropriate thing i feel like i'm going
to start and the lights are going to go
now this is too white this is
not how we want to do um i'm going to
ask my band to lay me down something
something groovy
um and we're gonna freestyle rap about
rumpelstiltskin
about violins income inequality andre
agassi's mullet and getting fingered at
the back of the comedy show
um this is uh gonna be thoroughly
enjoyable and we'll start with you cool
i ought to be aware all these things i'm
in the orchestra i'll be picking all the
strings let me tell you how i know i do
it italian pizzicato when they're there
on the four on the violin if you're on
the first chair i'll be settling in i'm
like ah pleasure to meet you hello what
the hell was the little cheer by the
cellos over there i'm a real move i
prefer all the violins screw the tubers
i don't need those the symphony would be
improved without the timpani i'm just
talking yeah in structure got the head
bobbing looking like the conductor
waving the wand moving the stick income
equality so sick i really hate that
these billionaires they be on stage
acting all silly they don't even care
about the people homeless with no money
no cash it's really not funny but we'll
bring it there in the rep anyway we need
to make sure that it goes away anyway
income equality i digress how do you fix
it legislation in congress that's the
only answer relax i'm not saying we
should increase the tax on the middle
class is all the people working i'm
talking about the billionaires who are
deserted they're like hi i'm jeff with a
face i want to fly high going out to
outer space that's the voice i do for mr
bezos weird little name just because but
the weirdest name that we're slipping in
a tiny little dwarf with a very cheeky
grin he's like hello there yes i'll walk
my name's rampal stiltskin we should
have a talk well he wouldn't introduce
himself that way otherwise she would
come right back with a name you can't
have my first born off the head i think
it was to do with weaving thread that
was something from the start of the
story then it got weird got a little bit
gory my name's rumpel i'm really crazy
can't guess my name then i'll take your
baby and i run away grabbing it with me
baby snatcher light agassi andre cause
book shields was underage maybe she was
older at this stage in their life used
to have a lot of hair and now he's
gotten on a ball dome on there he'd be
walking shining reflecting in the sun
but in the 1980s number one well not
technically that was pete sampras on the
little court yeah he got the answers
party at the back working the front
short hair long hair mullet like a i
apologize for even saying those things
but you were over there going like it
stinks the lights go down and it starts
to shimmer you like we can get sexy
while it gets dimmer you sidle up to the
lady by the side saying long fingers do
you mind if i slide i can move them
inside yeah i do i'm a cool dude produce
your own lube when i start getting
tickling it round finger in there yeah
it goes to town that's nice i really
like that sound got your fingers inside
in the village underground
[Music]